[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben wir machen heute
pudding brezel und ich weiß aus prien
brezel manchmal ziemlich kompliziert
sein können in der zubereitung aber ihr
kennt mich ich mag es einfach und
trotzdem super lecker und daher zeige
ich euch hier mal die zutaten für meinen
quark öl teig dem jetzt machen die
zutaten müsstet ihr auch eigentlich alle
zu hause haben wir benötigen mehr ganz
normales weizenmehl außerdem ein ei und
milch hier habe ich etwas magerquark ab
ich persönlich immer da backpulver
sonnenblumenöl und zucker und mehr
brauchen wir für den quark öl teig nicht
und ich fange jetzt auch schon direkt an
einmal mehl zucker und backpulver in die
schüssel geben und zusammen können
[Musik]
ja hier geht es direkt zur sache hamaya
wird direkt schon die flüssigen zutaten
rein getan und das sind wir einfach mal
eine saubere hände kurz noch die ärmel
so ein bisschen hochkrempeln und dann
ganz einfach kneten das dauert auch
jetzt wirklich nur 34 minuten
nach wenigen minuten habt ihr einen
schönen kompakten teig und diesmal ist
es wirklich so dass der tag echt etwas
fester ist wir wollen ihnen nämlich auch
so und bei mir wichtig jetzt zum
beispiel 730 gramm insgesamt dann rechne
ich mir das so ein bisschen aus also
durch 50 bei meinen teiglingen 50 gramm
wiegt weil beim bäcker habt immer so ri
sind pudding präsident nicht so groß und
ich mag es immer so ein bisschen kleiner
ja es ist viel zu groß und deswegen
mache ich halt immer 50 gramm große
teiglinge jetzt hier meine wunderschöne
taicang zieht man nicht bestimmt in der
spiegelung denkmal eine wunderschöne
tankkarte ein paar flecken von mir jetzt
drauf und dann teile ich mir den teig
einig bekommen so ungefähr 14 bis 15
sitze raus
[Musik]
den teig habe ich jetzt hier noch zu
kugeln gerollt und lasse ihn jetzt nur
auf der arbeitsfläche ein bisschen
entspannen also gehen muss ja nicht ist
ja kein hefeteig gibt aber auf jeden
fall ein küchentuch um drüber und jetzt
mache ich hier weiter mit meinem
vanillepudding und dafür zeige ich euch
mal ganz kurz die zutaten wir benötigen
einmal vanillepudding pulver und da gebe
ich immer ganz gern auch wenn in der
extrakt dazu damit so ein bisschen mehr
vanille aroma bekommt dann habe ich hier
noch zucker und selbstverständlich milch
und ich mache das jetzt so dass ich ein
teil der milch schon mal hier rein gebe
nur so ein fünftel und es gebe schon mal
mit zum zopf vanillepudding pulver
vanille extrakt und zucker habe ich hier
schon gegeben gut um geräte mit die
türmchen weg sind und jetzt mache ich
eben weiter hier auf dem herd meint ob
da habe ich jetzt nur die milch drin und
das lasse ich jetzt so langsam aufkochen
und sobald es anfängt hochzusteigen
geben wir die vanillepudding pulver
mischung mit dazu und lassen das unter
ständigem rühren einmal aufkochen
[Musik]
das ist jetzt der vanille pudding und
ihr seht auch schon was ein bisschen
dicker ist als regulär
weil wir haben ja auch die milch
reduziert damit dass eben dicker ist und
nicht ganz so viel ausgleich während des
backvorgang gibt es jetzt für nur kurz
zur seite der ist auch noch reis und ich
zeige euch jetzt wie ich die teiglinge
vorbereitet
dafür nehme ich mir einfach ein und
wollten jetzt zu einem dünnen strang aus
[Musik]
die briten sind fertig geformt und dann
habe ich sie auf ein mit backpapier
ausgelegtes backblech gelegt wichtig ist
ein bisschen abstand einzuhalten weil
nach dem backen wenn sie noch ein
bisschen aufgehen und ihr habt jetzt am
anfang in der szene gesehen mit dem
löffel ist ein bisschen schwierig den
putting green zu verteilen daher nimmt
euch am besten sind spritzbeutel vorher
spitze ab und dann könnte das ganz
einfach befüllt und auch noch mein tipp
von mir nicht so viel befüllen denn beim
backen wird der pulli noch mal ein
bisschen zu laufen und das ein bisschen
schade wenn er dann komplett da drüben
auf der anderen seite wäre und jetzt
packen wir das ganze bei 180 grad ober
und unterhitze für zirka 20 minuten je
nach ofen kann es auch abweichen
plus/minus zwei minuten sage ich mal
und dann sehen wir uns direkt nach dem
backen auch schon wieder so ganz frisch
aus dem ofen und ich finde die so schon
richtig richtig hübsch aber ich wollte
euch unbedingt etwas zeigen schaut man
den unterschied zwischen dem hier
da habe ich den löffel benutzt und
zwischen dem ihr mit dem spritzbeutel
die hits schaffen
vom geschmack her natürlich gleich aber
überzeugt dass genau und jetzt ganz ganz
wichtig die apres kultur in nehmt euch
ganz einfach aprikosenmarmelade gibt
sich für 30 sekunden bei 900 watt oder
die höchste warnstufe einfach in die
mikrowelle nehmt euch ein pinsel und
jetzt noch ganz heiß und ganz frisch
einmal bestreichen nicht das innere
sondern hier nur den teig
[Musik]
so meine lieben das ganze ist jetzt
schon fertig also nach der apricot tour
lassen ist es noch so ein bisschen
auskühlen damit ich mir gleich nicht den
mund verbrennen und dann gönne ich mir
erst mal sind wir nicht mehr so ein
lauwarm dann könnte ich mir später haben
aber noch so einen kalten und hamza auch
das kriegst natürlich auch was ab und
machen uns kaffee dazu ich will so
richtig in meiner fantasie wie ich hier
so pudding breze leben und mich auf dem
balkon setzte aber ich will dich jetzt
natürlich ganz viel spaß beim nachmachen
schreibt mir auf jeden fall feedback in
die kommentare wenn die es ausprobiert
hat oder was noch besser ist eure fotos
mit dem hashtag s kitchen auf instagram
besser geht es gar nicht
ansonsten einen daumen nach oben da
lassen wir euch das rezept gefallen hat
ein kostenloses aber sowieso und dann
sehen wir uns auch beim nächsten red
kleine anmerkung noch das sieht das
übrigens wurde ich euch entstanden weil
hier einige von euch geschrieben hat ihn
noch mal poliert sind daher immer
fleißig kommentieren was jetzt nächstes
sehen möchtet dann entstehen eben genau
so wie dies nur durch euch sowieso will
apple schon fast mit echt stelle heute
okay also bis dann in libyen
[Musik]